[Música]
hola buenas noches
yo sé que y abajo se están encargando de
frío pero no saben lo difícil que es
subir esta escalera con estos zapatos
bueno buenas noches mi nombre es cynthia
marihuana y esta noche como decía el
presentador quiero traerles un tema que
está bastante en sintonía con la
situación mundial que estamos
atravesando
hoy estamos siendo atravesados por la
enfermedad
y yo creo que depende de la mirada que
tengamos acerca de los hechos porque que
estemos atravesando una pandemia es un
hecho
va a ser que estemos del lado de la
dificultad o del lado de la posibilidad
y antes de eso
quiero hacerles un pedido que quizás
también haga que se olviden un poquito
del frío quiero pedirles que
vinculen con sus propios cuerpos y que
puedan sentir cada una de las emociones
que vienen a través de ustedes cuando
escuchan este relato
que las que las sostengan no se vayan a
la mente a dónde nos lleva la mente el
pensamiento sino simplemente qué me pasa
en el cuerpo que estoy sintiendo tengo
frío tengo calor tengo angustia me da
alegría si cada una de esas emociones
por favor registran las y sostenerlas
acción de pasión muy loco
escuchaba a dos personas que estaban
conversando y una le decía a la otra no
sabéis lo que me enteré
fulanito de tal se agarró cáncer uy no
le dicen a otra persona
y yo mientras escuchaba la conversación
pensaba en esta forma que tenemos de
relacionarnos con la enfermedad y decir
cómo es que se agarró cáncer
nos agarran en las enfermedades como
sería me imaginaba saliendo de casa
caminando o yendo a trabajar oa la
verdulería de la panadería y de repente
es un cáncer te lo agarras y te lo
llevas a tu casa
bueno me parece que las cosas no
funcionan de esa manera
también seguramente deben haber
escuchado que hay alguna relación entre
las emociones y la enfermedad
que hay enfermedades que tienen
trasfondo emocional que hay emociones
que pueden provocar enfermedades
pero
lo cierto es que yo no estoy segura de
que todas las enfermedades tengan un
trasfondo emocional que sean algunas
unas pocas unas muchas pero si les van a
contar una historia en la cual yo pude
chequear que esto es así
yo soy la mayor de cuatro hermanos era
una hermana mayor por acá
muy bien
[Música]
todos sabemos lo que es estar en el rol
de hermano mayor
y a mis 18 años siendo hermana mayor de
cuatro hermanos uno se editó atrás del
otro a pesar de que teníamos televisor
con mi hermano más pequeño me llevo casi
seis años así que saqué la cuenta
a mis 18 años tenemos la noticia de que
mi mamá se enferma de cáncer cáncer de
páncreas un cáncer fulminante terminal
en 9 meses y nos dijo
y yo como muy buena hermana mayor y
además les doy otro dato para los que
saben un poco de astrología tengo luna
en capricornio imposible que no me
hiciera cargo del claro entonces dije
bueno hay que hacerse cargo de esto
y empecé a hacer todas aquellas cosas
que hacía mi mamá
lavar planchar ocuparme de mis hermanos
que la casa esté siempre impecable
esperar a mi papá que venía de trabajar
y que era el sustento de esta familia
y bueno había que ser había que ser
había un montón de cosas que hacer y no
había mucho tiempo para pensar para
sentir y de hecho que tengo el recuerdo
de no haber llorado mucho la muerte de
mi mamá en ese momento yo creo que no
tenía tiempo y en ese momento también no
haberme permitido ese tiempo fue un
recurso para sobrevivir
que es el recurso que muchos tenemos a
veces
y
con estos 18 años y con muchas cosas que
hacer
un día me descubro una manchita en el
pecho en el medio del pecho cerca del
corazón
y por esos días mi mamá falleció el 30
de septiembre yo les estoy hablando de
hace 20 años atrás cuando los veranos en
esquel empezaba en septiembre no como
ahora
y ya hacía algo que por favor no lo
tomen como recomendación no hagan esto
en su casa me ponía a tomar sol a las
dos de la tarde ojalá que no vio nada
pero ojalá que me dermatóloga no esté
me voy a tomar sol a las 2 de la tarde y
me embadurnaba todo con aceite debe
imaginarse una fritura terrible
y en esos días me descubro esa manchita
blanca en el medio del pecho
y no olvide importancia porque dije
bueno debe haber sido justo el moñito de
la bikini que no me trapo ahí no me dio
el sol me dejó la manchita bueno resulta
que pasaron los días pasaron las semanas
pasaron algunos meses y la manchita
seguía y dije bueno vamos a ir a
consultar al dermatólogo
y cuando llego al consultorio del
dermatólogo le cuento la situación le
muestro la mancha y me dice
pero vos tenés vitíligo que le dio si
vitíligo
olvídate porque el vitíligo no asegura
no hay tratamiento vas a gastar fortuna
de plata en algo que no va a tener
solución así que bueno anda haciéndote
la idea de quedar totalmente blanca yo
en ese momento pensaba en michael
jackson y decía guau bueno
esto tiene que tener alguna otra
solución
y
me fui un poco abatida del consultorio
del dermatólogo pero como además soy
ascendente en actuar yo dije tiene que
haber otra solución vamos a innovar
vamos a buscar otras cosas y empecé
desde desde ese momento un largo camino
probando de todo crema cremita suyo
suscitó curandera
todo lo que se les pueda ocurrir lo
probé obviamente con muy pocos
resultados casi nulos y cada vez esas
manchas iban
ocupando cada centímetro de mi piel
y
yo ya no sabía qué más hacer
hasta qué
un día dije bueno basta ya está
alguien me dijo hay algo que tu cuerpo
te quiere decir hay algo que vos no
estás queriendo mirar hay algo que te
estás obligando a resistir
y con el transcurrir del tiempo fui
probando otras terapias conocí las
constelaciones familiares es a lo que me
dedico
y descubrí que no era casual que mi piel
el órgano más extenso que tenemos las
personas que es el que nos permite el
contacto con el exterior es el que nos
permite sentir el calor el frío una
caricia un golpe cuando algo nos da
vergüenza los ponemos colorados cuando
algo nos impacta que pasa nos ponemos se
los pone la piel de gallina
y
empecé a atar los cabos y me di cuenta
que en aquellos 18 años yo no había
sentido
no había
no me había dado cuenta que mi mamá no
iba a estar para el nacimiento de mis
hijos no me iba a ver crecer no me iba a
ver el primer día que fuese a buscar un
trabajo no me iba a estar esperando
nunca con un día de lluvia
y empecé a darme cuenta de la
importancia de hacernos cargo de
nuestras emociones
todas esas emociones que resistimos
todas las emociones que guardamos debajo
de la alfombra todas esas emociones
tienen los parámetros permitimos sentir
de alguna manera van a aflorar
y a veces podemos engañar la cabeza
podemos los podemos hackear y decir
bueno vamos a ir para adelante y no pasa
nada y todo va a estar bien y además el
este mundo en el que vivimos no nos
ayuda porque de chiquitos a todos nos
han dicho bueno no tranquilo no llores o
por qué lloras que sos [ __ ]
no tengas miedo como si estuviese mal el
tener miedo o como si llorar fuese
condición solamente femenina
entonces con este descubrir
me di cuenta que la sanación tiene que
ver con poder mirarnos primero desde
adentro y poder auto conocernos poder
hacernos cargo de todas esas emociones
que no nos estamos dejando sentir a
partir de ese momento cuando yo pude
cambiar la mirada empezaron a aparecer
las técnicas las terapias los
tratamientos y todo lo que hicieron que
mi vitíligo hoy esté sanado casi en un
100% todavía tengo algunas secuelas muy
chiquitas que hoy las miro con cariño y
son un recordatorio de que a este mundo
vinimos a sentir y que nada nos tiene
que distraer de eso
así que mi mensaje para hoy es cerrando
esta noche con ustedes es que viniste a
sentir no te distraigas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]